erica what's happening how are we doing
i'm calling to
get some advice on how to interact with
my 25 year old brother who's just
becoming a very
angry person particular in the
what he wants to do with his life
career-wise
he has a degree in business
administration and
graduated about uh 18 months ago and
since then he's had four different jobs
one of them he lost because he was the
new kid on the block for
covid so that was kind of you know out
of his control but
he comes to me you know asking for
advice and just gets very angry when i
either try to give him some advice or
guidance or suggestions
sometimes it's very very productive and
then other times it's i get hung up on
saying well you just don't know how it
is
kind of thing based on what he wants to
do
it's difficult because i i see him
starting to turn into an angry person
and kind of starting to distance himself
from
myself and my my parents so where does
this
where does your brother get this
sort of life from is he modeling that uh
yeah unfortunately i do start to see
some
transfer over my dad has kind of been
in and out of work for the last five
years
and it's i i don't tend to hear what the
reasoning why
he is no longer employed there but it's
always a there's other other people
caused the
determination of his employment kind of
thing and
so that's kind of put a strain on my mom
to handle all the finances on her own
and especially with um you know
all the things that are going on and
whatnot my dad just doesn't
really seem to have much interest
outside of
youtube and and whatnot so
um that's where all the good conspiracy
theories are erica
yeah well that and you know and this
thing and that thing and
yeah if you would quit working your
regular job and paying attention to your
regular family you could see
all the cool things on youtube including
this
this mildly entertaining show right well
yes you know of the 33 people that do
watch it i truly think those 33 get some
good advice out of it that's right so so
does your brother have
friends does he have people in his life
that are will
just tell me he's being an idiot or no
um
yes i would say so he switched colleges
midway through and so he has
more friends at the first college that
he started out with
um and he tries he seems to gravitate
more towards them but they
kind of live in a different area than
where he lives
he is actually moving out of my parents
house
in january finally kind of thing
more so it was he was trying to save
money
because it was expensive and then being
out of a job
living you know at home was just a
little bit easier but
um it's it's one of those i'm trying not
to be a second mom
to him because we're seven years apart
and kind of always been
the joke that he has two moms kind of
thing but you know
my dad and his brother don't have a good
relationship with each other
but i would like to keep that with my
brother but i also don't want to get
hung up on
or people i just don't know what i'm
talking about kind of thing whereas
you know if you're at a job for four
months and you want to leave within two
weeks of starting because you didn't get
adequate
training and then you know the
suggestion is we'll speak up
well no i can't do that and x y or z
reason kind of thing so here's i'll give
you some good news
and then some bad news okay and i'll go
with start with the bad news the bad
news is
you can do nothing yep there's nothing
you can do here to
help your brother do anything
differently yeah especially if he's not
coming to you
humbly and saying i need help with the
plan
and dude i am the worst there's been
seasons of my life when i've been the
worst brother i've got an older sister a
younger brother
where i've called them unsolicited just
giving them all kinds of shenanigans
like well you know what you should be
doing and it's insulting and it's
demeaning
and here's the thing i think i was right
i probably still think i was right
but it wasn't helpful right and so
talk backing out and talking about your
brother here's what your brother is he's
25 he said
yeah your brother's terrified yeah
and he's terrified of two different two
different tracks number one
those feelings he has that people at
work don't like him that everyone around
him is out to get him
those feelings aren't truthful they're
not right but they feel
real and that's scary
and yeah depending on how your dad and
your mom raised him
guys have very limited skills in
responding to fear and usually it's to
puff your chest out and just start
swinging
or it's to numb it out and you can numb
out with alcohol with youtube
with more work or with another job and
another job or another girlfriend or
another girlfriend another drink
but you're just going to spend your life
numbing and running right
yeah the second thing definitely been
he's definitely been the person his
whole life that school was hard for him
teachers were out to get him
right um and when throw my hands up any
time that it got
gets difficult and have somebody else
figure it out there you go
okay mom and dad and that leads me to
number two which is he is terrified of
becoming his dad
and it's happening before his his very
eyes it's like watching somebody who's
dad is bald and it's that first time you
swipe your comb through
and you just see all that hair come out
and you're like oh no right it just it
happens in slow motion
to your life and oh
so here's the thing you have a scared to
death 25 year old little brother that
you can't help
yeah all you can do for him is to love
him
and to say i you can call me anytime
here's my recommendation to you and it's
gonna be trite and not
super helpful um it will be when he
calls you to ask your
opinion on things i would stop him
before he gets rolling which
i'm guaranteeing he's a roller he'll
talk and just talk and talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk and talk
and you'll start to try to get in he'll
just take a breath and keep going
is i'm right am i right on that oh yeah
okay so i would start him i'll stop him
before he gets going and ask him
do you want my um advice or you just
need somebody to listen to because i'd
love to listen to you
and let him choose because then if you
start to pipe up with here's what i
think you need to do
you can always fall back on hey you
asked me for this
yeah otherwise just be a safe quiet
place for him to talk and vent and talk
and vent
and then you need to live your life
above reproach and what i mean by that
is
you will be a shining light you'll be
the example for him that he doesn't have
right and you may reach out to him with
with good things that are happening in
your life you may reach out with him
just to check on him you may write
him letters that tell him that he's
loved and he's a good guy
and that when he when he does something
good we do that with kids right catch
him being good
but write him a actual physical letter
that he can hold in his hands that's
tactile that he can see it
and he's a millennial he won't even know
what's happening he'll be like what's
this
mail thing you speak of right but send
him a letter he can open it and see it
and touch it and feel it
and he's gonna have to learn
a really hard and uncomfortable lesson
and that is work sucks
and the real world's hard and nobody
gives you anything
and you've got a phil you know right
fill in the blank all those things sure
and that does lead me to this um it's
almost
i don't want to be all ranty today here
in this new studio it's all shiny
i don't want to get spittle everywhere
but
there's a whole generation of young
person who's been told this one
like fascinating line which is follow
your passions
almost like it's you say it you say i'm
breathy follow your passions right like
the deeper
like a like a mega church preacher when
we're just talking in regular voices and
then they're like
so one day i was walking along the road
and then i met god they have to only say
it in a breathy breathy way right
it's the same way follow your passions
and
for most kids there's no backup to that
there's no information that goes along
with that and so what passion becomes is
a marker for feelings
follow your feelings do the thing that
feels most comfortable to you
and if there's any sort of resistance if
things are hard
i want to be an author well just write a
book and then the first person reads it
like hey this book kind of sucks that's
not good
or you've got to pay attention to
english class so you can learn how
an actual sentence functions right or
fill in the blank i want to be a poet i
want to be a runner i want to be a
whatever follow your passions that means
follow your feelings
and then when things get hard then i
feel sad i don't want to feel sad so i
just
abandon it and quit i go somewhere else
and that's just absolutely wreaked havoc
on a whole generation of human being
and really it starts with my generation
they were telling us follow your dreams
follow your passions you can be anything
here's the thing about follow your
passions
you become passionate about the things
you're good at
and you become good at the things that
you practice
the things that you do over and over and
over and over again
and if you're like 99.9 of the world
there's always that one kid that just
sits in front of youtube learns how to
play the guitar and he comes out nine
months later and he's a savant
every generation has that kid good for
you i'm not talking about them
most of you are not steve jobs right or
you wouldn't be listening to this
podcast
the rest of us practice the things that
we were made to do
my parents made me be really good at
mowing the yard my dad
was really hard on me about mowing the
yard because he said it communicated a
couple of things it communicated how i
cared about a customer it communicated a
sense of excellence that was inborn
regardless how much i was making
it was a sense of pride for the
homeowner all these things came through
right
joe and linda there at burger king treat
the customer that comes in here
with respect you don't know where
they're coming from we happen to be on a
route to a hospital people would stop
there to get food to go visit their
loved ones at a hospital
just laughing and bringing joy into that
day brighten people up right
but we were made to do it if you treated
a customer with disrespect they called
you in the back and they
said you're not going to work here if
you're like that right and so
you're passionate about things you're
good at you're good at things your
practice your practice the things you're
made to do
and when you're made to do things it's
hard and you don't like it and it's not
fun and there's some times that you are
practicing things and you have good days
of practice and bad days of practice
right
there are sometimes you are things doing
things that you're really good at and
then you don't do them good that day
you don't do them good that month you
have a low season you work really hard
on your next big book
and it tanks right steven spielberg has
some movies that didn't do well
that's part of it and
being told to do things that are hard
being made to do things that are hard is
not mean to your children it's not mean
to your students it's not mean to
teenagers
it gives them a sense of fortitude
and grit that comes from the inside out
the fancy word for that is resilience
not feelings feelings are true you got
to sit down and
i mean not true feelings are real you
got to sit down and acknowledge them but
they lie to you
and this sounds like a young man that
has been told
his entire life yeah you know what
i know you feel that that teacher is
being mean to you you're right let's go
get her
i know you feel like that job's hard you
should quit they should treat you better
and you feel your feelings feel your way
through 100 different jobs
through frustration through broken
relationships
no no work to stand upon
and when you don't have any work to
stand upon you don't have relationships
to stand upon you are
nothing we are made as relationships we
are made to work period that's just the
way that is
and so for everybody out there who is
doubling down on like what's my passion
what's my passion
go back to the things you were made to
do go back to the things that you're
going to practice
over and over and over and over these
poor james and kelly
zach these poor folks you should see the
hours of tape
that we have on they called it radio
school
these guys back it was a beating it
still is a beating for them i'm still
learning how to do this right
but we had to practice and practice and
then james would say we're going to be
here at this time you've got to be here
at this time
and it would be uncomfortable not good
they made me do it and you get better
and better and now i'm starting to love
it
now i'm starting to like it it's
starting to be fun i'm starting to be
quote unquote passionate about it right
so erica to answer your original
question there's nothing you can do man
you can love your brother be connected
to your brother i'd stop on the advice
unless he explicitly asks
and you can feel free to tell him this
if i tell you this i'm going to hold you
accountable to it okay
and he may not want to do that he may
say
whatever 25 year olds with five jobs in
four months say
but man just gets me frustrated dude all
right i'm gonna quit talking on it